problem 17 problem 17 the
three-dimensional figure above has two
parallel bases in 18 edges or I could
try to draw it but well he'll let me
draw that let me draw that so the base
so what their bases are both hexagons
essentially so have one base it looks
like this you know maybe i should draw
it with dwelled on me let me draw it i
have time so let me draw it properly so
the base in front looks like something
like this like this like this this and
like that and then the top base is just
a small version our smaller version that
looks like that whoops
and then they draw these are the front
edges look something like this
I'll do the rear edges in a darker color
just so you know that they're in the
back since their rear edge well I should
have done them later because there let
me switch back to this and just paint
over let's just you know these are in
front those are in front okay good
enough and they said they tell us that
this point up here this point up here is
V I don't side even fit on the video but
hopefully you can see that point up
there the three-dimensional figure above
has two parallel basis right this is one
base that's the other base to peril
bases in 18 edges line segments are to
be drawn connecting vertex V with each
of the other 11 vertices each of the 11
vertices in the figure how many of these
segments will not lie on an edge of the
figure so an edge of the figure is
essentially let's see what they're
saying they're saying in 17 line segment
will be drawn connecting vertex V with
each of the other 11 or to see so what
are the other 11 vertices let me draw
them this is one let me do it a brighter
color this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
and they want to know how many of these
segments will not lie on an edge of the
figure and actually think this is a
little ambiguous because if something is
on the face of the figure on a base ok
well there's think the edges they're
defying the edges as the line so you
know it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 inches so it can lie on a
face and still count so what are how
many of these how many of these line
segments can I draw well this if I were
to draw a line segment with every point
on this base that is not on an edge so
this one won't count right because that
is on an edge right
but I could draw 10 I should do a
different color because this is going to
get messy I can draw one two three right
because I'm connected to the other two
with an edge so that I have three there
and then how many can I draw a line
segment two on the other that I am not
connected already with an edge well the
way to think about it is this point is
connected to this only here right so we
can't we can't use this as one of the
line segments but then there's five
other points that it can connect to
where you're not going through an edge
so you're going one two three four five
so there's five more three plus five is
equal to eight and if you wanted to do
that even without drawing it you can
send well okay there's two types of
vertices they're the ones that are on
the top base and the ones that are on
the bottom base on the top base which
was a hexagon right this was our point
right here on the top base with the
hexagon there are six there are five
other vertices right one two three four
five but you're connected directly to
two of them so there's only going to be
three that you can go where you're not
already connected to them and that
likewise on the bottom base on the
bottom base if this was the bottom base
vertex V was only directly connected to
this one right it had an edge directly
to that one but the other five it didn't
have a direct edge to so all of those
would have been fair game for the
problem so five on the bottom it can
connect you and three on the top or
that's where we got our eight from next
problem alright this looks like
something that I need to draw that's my
x-axis that's my y-axis label them x
why and then they draw a rectangle doing
a different color it looked something
like this looks like that and what did
they how did they label it they said
that this point C is the point one-half
comma C this point B is the point minus
one-half comma B minus one-half comma B
my microphone is hitting my sweatshirt
and then let's see this point here a is
minus one half a and then finally this
point here d is one-half comma D and
then they do a graph in between this
whole thing that intersects it goes from
here starts to flatten out star already
looking like kind of like an X cubed
graph if you're familiar with what an
execute graph looks like going to go
through that point of course there's a
point here okay don't figure not drawn
to scale and the figure above ABCD is a
rectangle points a and C lie on the
graph of y equals P X cubed right this
is why it looked like y equals P X cubed
fair enough where p is a constant if the
area of ABCD is for what is the value of
P so area is base times height all right
can we figure out what the base is well
sure we know that this is one half right
because the coordinates of these to the
x coordinate is one half we know that
this is minus one half because the
coordinates of these two are the x
coordinate is minus one half so if this
is one half this length is one half this
length is one half we know this entire
base is one right so if we know the area
is for of this entire rectangle what is
this height this height this
distance it's going to have to equal 4
because 4 times 1 is the area and four
times one equals four so this has this
has to have height for and this is
symmetric right because well do we know
that it's a symmetric well we do
actually do we know that it's a
symmetric it's a rectangle points lie on
the graph do you know how we know it's
symmetric because this is y equals P X
cubed and anything that is P X cubed
would be symmetric like this that as as
far at one-half whatever point it is at
see it would be at a similar point down
here right but it would just be on the
other side and in the third quadrant so
it's kind of like you're flipping it
over the origin but anyway so if we
assume that that's symmetric then we
know that this distance is too this
distance is minus 2 right if this
distance is too then now we know a point
on this graph we know that C must be
equal to 2 right because that's the y
coordinate now we have a point on the
graph and we can substitute it back in y
equals P X cubed so let's put 24 hour
why cuz we know that that's a point on
the graph right we know the point one
half 2 is on the graph so if we put 2
for y we get 2 is equal to p times the x
value p times one-half cubed 1 a half
cubed so 2 is equal to P over 8 all
right one-third cubed oh sorry one sorry
I can't do math I did one half over
cubed one-third cubed is 27 no it's all
right 27 3 squared 9 27 so P multiply
both sides by 27 is equal to 54 and all
we did here is we just said well let's
figure out what this side is we know
this side is 1 because we can look at
the minus one half of the one-half so
this side has to be four if this side is
four and it's symmetric it goes just a
bunch as above the x-axis is below and
we know that's this is an X third X
cubed function we know that this side
must be to whether the y coordinate is 2
and then we just substitute into y is
equal to
p x cubed to solve for P I'll see you
soon